movie is so much yeah you know it's it's  very heartfelt we're dealing with the  legacy of Chadwick Boseman and the loss  of Chadwick and you know the loss of the  character t'challa yeah so everyone in  the movie is dealing with that grief and  ambaku serves almost as that little  valve on the pressure cooker that lets  some of the steam out so gets everyone  to laugh a little bit by telling some of  the truths that other people aren't  ready to hear yes like that  um and and that function is you know  it's incredible now before filming  started the cast together went to go to  Chadwick's resting place dress what did  you all do what when did you do that and  what did you do so we did that about the  Sunday before we started shooting and it  was just our chance to say goodbye  because it all happened so sudden yeah  when it all happened none of us knew he  was even sick